حريه الصحافه في تونس تجاوز كل الخطوط
الحمر هكذا وصفت نقابه الصحفيين سلسله
الملاحقات القضائيه التي شملت صحفيين
ومدونين وناشطين واخرها صدور حكم بسجن
صحفي خمس سنوات كامله الصحفي محمد بوغلاب
الذي شارك في الوقفه المندده باستهداف
الصحفيين يجري التحقيق معه في دعوى رفعها
ضده احد الوزراء اللي عايشين اليوم وضع
غير مسبوق انه هذا الكم الهائل للتزامن
تاع الملاحقات والتتبعات
مرسومه
54.86 هضم جانب موظف يعني تنجو من فخ تلقى
فخ واحده
اضافه الى البيانات الصحفيه والتقارير
الدوريه
تتحرك نقابه الصحفيين على اكثر من صعيد
بعد تواتر ما تقول انه استهداف ممنهج
للصحفيين لاسيما اثر صدور المرسوم 54
المثير للجدل هذا الكل يتنزل في عام
لمتابعه الصحفيين متابعتهم عن ارائهم عن
اختلافاتهم عن تعدديه اللي هي موجوده
داخلهم فبالتالي احنا اليوم في مواجهه خطر
داهم اتي من رئاسه الحكومه ورئاسه
الجمهوريه ومؤسسات الدوله
ينفي الرئيس قيس سعيد اي استهداف للحقوق
او الحريات لا بل انه يشدد على ان حريه
التعبير والتفكير مكفوله
ويستشهد بالدستور الجديد والمراسيم التي
اصدرها دليلا دامغا على ذلك واخرها موقفه
الرافض لايقاف الشابين بسبب نشر مقطع
غنائيا ينتقد المؤسسه الامنيه ليطلق
سراحهما لاحقا فليكون الامر واضحا بالنسبه
للجميع اننا نكره الظلم ونكره ان يتم
التنكيل
بطلباتنا وبابناء شعبنا
دعوه مره اخرى لان ينخرط القضاه الشرفاء
في معركه التحرير الوطني تتصاعد موجه
الانتقادات التي تشمل السلطات في ظل
استمرار الملاحقات القضائيه ضد الصحفيين
ما يلقي بظلال من الشك على وضع الحريات
الصحفيه والعامه رغم التطمينات الرسميه
الجزيره تونس